what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so for the past couple weeks or so
we have been remastering Jonathan
Hitman's Avengers and New Avengers and I
mean the original contents there I just
felt like remastering it is kind of a
side project I don't really like the way
it was it was done initially but because
of the fact that that's really just kind
of reach treading water this is more
important so it is officially the
beginning of 2018 and we have about four
months in two days until we see the
launch of Marvel's you know infinity war
movie Avengers infinity Wars so my job
over the course of the next four months
is to make you guys experts in
everything Marvel cosmic covering the
original Cosmic Cube story when Thanos
invaded earth for the first time the
three major deaths that Thanos has had
characters like Adam warlock who we're
gonna discuss here all these things the
events leading up to Infinity Gauntlet
the aftermath of Infinity Gauntlet
infinity war infinity Crusade all that
stuff all the Marvel cosmic things my
job is to cover all that stuff and we
are starting with Adam warlock today so
Adam warlock first made his appearance
in Marvel Comics back in 1967 with
Fantastic Four issue 66 and 67 now one
thing to keep in mind here is that in
the early days of Marvel Comics when it
came to stay and Lee and Jack Kirby
everything was basically a testing
ground model didn't really explode onto
the scene until about 1962 I mean when
you look back at the old 1940s comics
you know the old name with a submariner
Jim Hammond the Human Torch Captain
America comics that was timely
publications but between the time of
World War 2 's and and the fact that
timely stop publishing superheroes all
the way up to the early 1960s when
timely became Atlas atlas became Marvel
there was this huge wall of about 20
years when there really were no
superhero comics coming out of timele
instead it was science fiction general
magazines published by magazine
management incorporated and so in 1962
when Marvel really launched Fantastic
Four when they launched spider-man
different things like that
they were basically trying to come back
onto a scene of the comic book genre
which had largely been dominated by DC
for you know however many decades and so
as a result the Fantastic Four were the
most popular team they had it was
Marvel's answer to the Justice League
and so because of that if mother was
going to premiere characters they were
going to premiere teams they threw them
in the Fantastic Four now for Adam
warlock himself this two-part story was
pretty straightforward all that really
happened in this origin was that you
basically had a group called The Enclave
and The Enclave were basically just a
general group of scientists who wanted
to conquer the world that was really
about it but the enclave knew that in
order to pull this off with this rise of
C
out there they needed a being of virtual
incalculable power who was wildly
capable in terms of what he could do and
could easily thwart all these different
superheroes and so what they ended up
doing was basically taking all this
different you know cosmic energy more or
less could finding it into a cocoon and
then letting it form into a human being
the problem with this was that they
couldn't visually look at the being
inside because the amount of energy
giving a given off was too extreme and
so what the enclave ended up doing is
they kidnapped Alicia masters who at the
time was the girlfriend of Ben Grimm but
she was blind that she was a sculptor
but she was well known for the fact that
she could sculpt virtually anything just
by feeling it and then making an almost
perfect replica of it and so the result
is that they kidnapped her they brought
her to the enclave and they had her
sculpt out what Adam warlock looked like
now of course this led directly into the
Fantastic Four
arriving to retrieve Alicia masters
battling The Enclave Adam warlock made
his escape and then took off for parts
unknown and the whole basis behind that
was to basically say there's this new
character out there now whoever wants to
ride him run away with it do whatever it
is that you want to do now originally
because of the fact that he was just
kind of a general creation that was
thrown out there for virtually any rider
to pick up he wasn't actually given a
name instead Adam warlock was just
referred to as him and that was really
about it now following this there wasn't
really anything going on when he came to
Adam warlock after his initial
introduction into the Fantastic Four
instead it was about two years after his
original appearance before he appeared
again and this came in a Stanley Jack
Kirby's story with Thor issues 165 and
166 between June and July of 1969 now
the funny thing about this is that
because of the fact that nobody was
really picking up the slack Staley and
Jack Kirby just threw out a Morlock out
there was kind of a hey remember this
guy still exists out there if anybody
wants to ride him it was kind of
interesting in terms of how it played
out because at this point in time Adam
warlock was kind of on a grander scale
in comparison to the silver surfer and
what I mean by that is well the Silver
Surfer appeared in the original you know
Galactus trilogy
and was spun off into his own series
whereby he basically traveled around the
world and learned about humanity why
people do the kind of things they do and
how humans perceive the universe and
themselves and so on and so forth
Adam warlock was like that but on a
grander scale the difference is that the
Silver Surfer already had knowledge of
all things in existence so his only real
curiosity was just the nature of
humanity for Adam warlock or him if we
want to call Matt uh he was really kind
of infantile in this sense that he
really didn't understand the nature of
everything that was
there it was really more exploration was
effectively walking out of his house for
the very first time and a lot of those
themes were played on when it came to
his introduction and his involvement in
Thor and different things along those
lines the problem is that once this
story was done it would be about three
years again before Adam warlock made his
appearance the difference is that by
this point in time in 1972 Stan Lee had
moved from being a writer to an editor
to basically the president and publisher
of Marvel and the idea of Stan Lee was
to sit down and say by this point in
time were 10 years out from our
effective relaunch more or less with
Fantastic Four Spiderman different
things along those lines and the
landscape of Marvel was rapidly growing
but for the most part by the early 1970s
they pretty much knew what characters
were solid and what characters aren't
they knew that the Fantastic Four were
solid they knew Spiderman was solid Thor
Iron Man Captain America different
things like that but the whole idea
behind Stan Lee's perception of Marvel
was we don't have the money to just
throw marketing out there for any
character in any comic book that we want
to write instead we need to be selective
but we also want to make sure that we're
growing our writer base that we're
growing our artist base that we still
have fans that are learning about new
characters all as hot and so what
Stanley had done is he had actually
launched the Marvel premiere alongside a
couple of other one-off publications
called Marvel spotlight and Marvel
feature and what these were designed to
do were basically serve as an anthology
series it was really kind of a throwback
to the 1930s Marvel stories and 1930s DC
stories in the sense that actually
comics 1 for example while that that
comic is most notable for the debut of
Superman it featured a handful of other
stories alongside it because the idea
was to just introduce characters
introduce teams put them and you know
maybe eight page stories and see whether
or not fans liked them and what they
would do is they would shuffle things up
so you would see a character appear and
Marvel premiere for like three or four
issues and Marvel would gauge the sales
of it and if the stories were consistent
Marvel would say okay most likely
they're reading this because this one
character is in this story he's been in
the last three stories that's what fans
are shooting for we'll take a risk and
we'll give him their own publication and
that's really what happened with the
character of Adam warlock one thing to
keep in mind here is that when it came
to the character of Adam in terms of
where he would go or what he would do
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's explanation
for what would happen to him was largely
just kind of relegated to the idea that
well you know he would fight some enemy
like he would fight Thor he would try to
procreate with SIF Thor would beat the
crap out of him and then he would just
go heal in a cocoon somewhere and in
truth
was really just kind of a throwaway idea
it was just a way for Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby to explain where he went to just
like you know the Avengers would go back
to Avengers Tower Captain America would
go to his apartment or something along
those lines it was a throwaway concept
but the irony is that with Marvel
premiere number one Android Thomas
really kind of being brought on board by
Stan Lee as a fledgling writer because
of the fact that he fit nicely into this
whole idea of using Marvel premiere and
spotlight and feature and so on as a
proving ground for whether or not a
person could actually write stories what
do I miss did is he took the whole idea
of the cocoon he rolled it over into the
actual Adam warlock mythos and then in
turn expanded the nature of warlock now
one thing to keep in mind is that when
it came to Adam warlocks character the
reason why people say he's so important
is because he helped to kind of assure
in and build on this idea of Marvel
Comics becoming more grounded and more
real-world in terms of how they were
depicted I mean back in 1971 really the
year before Marvel premiere debuted
Gerry Conway had already killed off Gwen
Stacy so it had already been established
that like a superhero like spider-man
could fail disastrously and basically
lose his love interest because of his
own actions and so the idea was to take
some real world themes and throw them
into Marvel comic characters the issue
with this was that it was very very
risky it was not something Marvel could
just do and expect the fan base to be
perfectly on board and so what ended up
happening here is Roy Thomas created
something called a counter-earth saga
and what this did is it introduced the
concept of a place called counter-earth
now a little bit of history here back in
for issue number 134 in 1966 Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby introduced a character by
the name of Herbert Windham High
Evolutionary was introduced and has been
expanded on over the years as a guy
who's basically obsessed with evolution
of course he vote he's evolved himself
but he creates new forms of life and
different things like that but there's
always been this ongoing theme of
dissatisfaction with the existing world
on behalf of the High Evolutionary and
so what Roy Thomas did is he grabbed his
character he grabbed the themes of his
character he grabbed the character of
Adam warlock and rolled them all
together and so counter-earth was
basically this alternate version of
earth that existed on the other side of
the Sun but was about a second or two
outside of the dimensional barrier of
Earth meaning no more Earthlings
wouldn't see it and essentially
counter-earth was kind of like this
utopian place the problem with this was
account of Earth didn't really have any
superheroes to speak of however the
actions of the High Evolutionary in
terms of some of his creations being
sent to counter earth
resulted in the emergence of a character
known as man beast now this is very
important and the reason why was because
in order for Rory Thomas to create the
kind of religious themes that he wanted
to do again he had to focus on an
alternate version of the earth as it
existed in Marvel Comics and so with
counter-earth and with Adam warlock what
he created were these very christ-like
themes in the sense that Adam warlock
himself was very much like Jesus Christ
and along the way on his mission to
basically defeat man beast
he met like four people it was like
David Carter Jason gray I think it was
and then like Eddie Roberts in a girl
named Allie I came over her last name I
want to say it's Ellie Roberts but I'm
not gonna swear to that I mean we're
talking about comics in the 1970s so I'd
like to think I know a lot but I don't
know that much but the fact remains here
that with regard to these characters
these these four folks they were
basically designed to be like his own
not really prophets but I guess his
followers they were basically Chronicle
the actions of Adam now of course with
regards to warlock getting its first
name Adam that was given to him I
believe by Ellie and again that's
designed to be a homage to very
judeo-christian themes in the sense that
according to biblical scripture Adam was
the name of the first being created by
God so again it was designed to very
much be in that vein now of course man
beast and the counter-earth saga was
really kind of this allegory for Satan
in the sense that man beast was this
Satan like figure he was the ultimate
evil on counter-earth and Adam warlock
was the ultimate good know in order to
arm Adam warlock for his battle against
the man beast what high evolutionary had
done is of course woken him up brought
him out of his cocoon and then gave him
the soul Jim and the soul Jim was one of
the very first indications of these
insane levels of power that existed out
there but the soul Jim as it was created
by Roy Thomas and Marvel premiere number
one was never really intended to go on
to be what it is which is to say part of
the Infinity stones and different things
like that a lot of that was you know jim
Starlin grabbing all these themes and
just kind of rolling them together in
the Thanos stories but the fact remains
here but the soul Jim was basically used
by Adam warlock to kind of enhance his
abilities but you know it was also
toying on this idea that the soul Jim
house soul world you know it was
actually able to trap Souls different
things along those lines
but with Adam warlock the battle between
himself and man beasts really stretched
for the first two parts of Marvel
premier model / ears 1 & 2 and then
really it was just kind of defeated and
then forced back into his original form
but following this again this sort of
return of evil so to speak began to take
its form in the power of warlocks solo
series and this really ran for about a
issues up until about October of 1973
and he was designed he's just kind
continue the themes that were found in
Marvel premiere but because of the fact
that that warlock was so popular among
readers at the time what Roy Thomas did
is he basically spun out the remainder
of the fight between man beast and Adam
warlock in power of warlock issues 1 & 2
now following the defeat of man beasts
going into issues 3 through 8 it was
really kind of like this exploration of
what the what counter-earth was like and
it was really designed to be the
original home of Adam warlock it was
basically gonna be where his stories
took place where he would travel to the
main Marvel earth from time to time but
for the most part he would stay confined
on counter-earth as it's only real
superhero very much maintaining these
christ-like themes and these concepts
with regards to how his character
function but the issue with this when it
came to the character of Adam was that
by this point in time 1971-1972 Roy
Thomas was making massive contributions
to Marvel Comics we're writing things
like the kree-skrull war characters like
Ultron different things like that and
because of the work that he put in when
Stanley was promoted to the position of
president Roy Thomas was moved to
editor-in-chief and what this meant was
that it only really allowed Roy Thomas
to focus on the most popular titles that
he was writing at the time and while
Adam warlock did have a following among
fans it was very similar to the original
following of Doctor Strange in the sense
that it was only a small niche group of
people and so the result was that
following the writing of Roy Thomas what
he really did here is he just kind of
wrapped up the plot threads from the
original power of warlocks story in some
strange tale comics different things
like that this ultimately ran up until
jim Starlin took over the title and the
reason why this is so important is
because where Roy Thomas had made Adam
warlock a kind of christ-like figure jim
Starlin expanded the cosmic scope he
basically brought Adam warlock into this
role of being more of a universal
christ-like figure as opposed to just
one on counter-earth and so running
between 1975 all the way up to December
of 1977 the power of warlock series was
continued on numerically running between
issues 9 to 15 and then of course the
last little tidbits were finished up in
like Marvel team-up and Avengers annual
and Marvel 2 and 1 different things like
that but the whole idea was to basically
introduce a character called The Magus
and one of the things this did was focus
on the possibility of Adam warlock
becoming a villain and if Adam warlock
became a bad guy if he basically became
everything he stood against what would
that villain look like and so what uh
what jim Starlin did is he crafted this
story he basically said at some point in
the future Adam warlock
we'll become corrupted by the soul Jim
he possesses and when he does he'll form
a religious sect called the universal
Church of Truth which will be his
mindless followers more or less and the
result is they will do whatever it is
that he wants them to do this will cause
him to grow in madness and so on and so
forth and so in an effort to keep this
from happening what we ended up having
were all these different themes again
that came together the introduction of
characters like Gomorrah creation of pit
Patrol Thanos being brought in and so
that knows his desire to continue
gaining power fit in very very nicely
with the role that Adam warlock played
because word saw the two of them team up
for the most part at the end of the day
where Magus was basically defeated it
was always this lingering possibility
that Adam warlock could become the Magus
and so again it was really fans being
brought in and kind of an underhanded
way in the sense that he was well I'll
help you keep from becoming the Magus
all the while plotting and scheming and
trying to find ways to steal the soul
gem from from Adam warlock himself now
again following this because of the fact
that the writing of jim Starlin with
regards to the handling of adam warlock
and even the writing of roy thomas
wasn't the most well received among the
larger fanbase of Marvel and because of
the fact that the mid-1970s were
starting to seek this expansive scope of
the Marvel cosmology with the
introduction of characters like quasar
Silver Surfer Galactus Tim and things
like that there wasn't really a whole
lot of room for a character like like
Adam warlock who didn't really have
stories that were granting to in terms
of the cosmic scope and so what jim
Starlin did is he set the seeds for
future use of Adam when it came to the
last little tidbits of his own story and
what it effectively happened here is
that Gamora had been assigned to the
role of a bodyguard for Adam warlock and
then Adam warlock learned the true
nature of the soul Jim in the sense of
the soul Jim was one of six Infinity
stones now of course this also allowed
Adam were like to kind of enter the soul
stone and then just stay there and so
what ended up happening is about eleven
years after the last you know tidbits of
this story Adam warlock effectively
vanished off the face of the earth out
of Marvel's publication history and he
didn't come back until we basically got
the aftermath of Thanos in Silver Surfer
vol 3
issue number 34 and what jim Starlin did
is he basically laid the groundwork for
the return of Adam warlock by virtue of
a story called the Infinity Gauntlet and
what this did is an introduce the idea
that Thanos had been traveling around
and gaining all these different Infinity
stones for the most part and the return
of Adam warlock of course leaving the
soul stone so on and so forth coincided
with this sort of grander scope in terms
of what jim Starlin perceived him to be
so over the course of the Infinity
Gauntlet story which you'll find down in
the description Adam warlock wasn't
really a guy who engaged in the fight
per se instead he played very much this
leadership role he didn't really act
overtly he directed other people in
terms of the roles that they should play
but this expansion of Adam warlock came
with the idea that there's this kind of
nature about the universe and the forces
that encompass it that nobody else
really seems to have and so because of
this Adam warlock basically organized
the united front of the earth
superheroes against Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet he organized this
front from the cosmic entities it was
one of these things were Starlin
effectively established that on a cosmic
scale Adam warlock is well known and
well respected by a lot of the entities
the other half of this was that the
possibility of Adam warlock becoming a
villain was still very real in terms of
the role the Magus played and so
following the events of Infinity
Gauntlet whereby Adam warlock was able
to secure the gauntlet for himself bring
the conflict to an end this led directly
into the story's aftermath and then led
directly into infinity war so again it
was kind of like this massive infinity
story that was done by jim Starlin
himself with regards to the character of
adam now one of the things is Starlin
played on here when it came to infinity
war was that he formed something called
warlock in the infinity watch it was
basically this idea that in the
aftermath of the Infinity Gauntlet
because of the fact that all Fano sought
was absolute power that it was like okay
fine he can even take the place of
eternity and he could have the Infinity
Gauntlet according to the Living
Tribunal but for Adam warlock himself he
would look to rule over the universe not
as an entity but as a supreme judge of
what's right and wrong the problem here
is that Adam warlock didn't understand
the nature of people on a true scale and
so this argument basically meant that
Adam warlock was neither equipped
mentally or emotionally to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet and the power it
possessed the Living Tribunal agreed and
ordered Adam warlock to disperse the
gems and so forcing the disbanding of
the Infinity Gauntlet and then going a
next step and saying if all the gems are
brought together they will never work
allow for you know the formation of the
Infinity watch whereby Adam warlock rat
pip the troll he grabbed moon dragon the
daughter of Drax a destroyer and gave
each of them an infinity stone he even
gave one to Thanos and simply said your
job will be to safeguard these things
these led directly into the events of
infinity war whereby we ended up
learning that Adam had subconsciously
purged himself with good and evil which
is the whole reason for why he was
deemed unworthy that the evil version of
himself the Magus had basically made a
return and infinity
or picked up from there with Adam
warlock basically having to fight an
evil version of himself that led an
affinity crusade whereby Adam warlock
had to fight the purely good version of
himself known as goddess but over the
course of it all jim Starlin constantly
began to expand and really emphasize
this relationship that existed between
Adam warlock and fan O's that were the
two of them were enemies in a lot of
ways they were also extremely close in
terms of their greater understanding of
the cosmology and so what is ended up
doing is it actually allowed jim Starlin
to spin out a litany of infinity books
that were isolated from the main Marvel
Universe line of stories that focused
almost explicitly on Adam warlock and
Thanos now again because of the fact
that these stories of Infinity Gauntlet
and infinity war even infinity crusade
were so incredibly popular among Marvel
readers at the time the stories of Adam
warlock were actually bolstered by
virtue of the writing of jim Starlin so
what this meant was that instead of
warlock in the infinity watch being what
amounted to a maxi series which is about
12 issues long instead it was spun out
into a series that ran for 42 issues it
ran all the way up until 1995 the
problem with this was that the success
of Adam warlock really began to give way
to a lot of different things the
notorious coming bust of the 1990s the
fact that stories were designed to be
more high-octane more fast paced but the
stories of Adam warlock didn't really
keep up with that that style of
storytelling and even the fact that a
lot of readers were getting burned out
and so because of that Adam warlock
effectively fell back into the middle of
no man's land now Marvel tried a couple
times to kind of revive interest and his
character throwing him off into like
ultraverse stuff and things like that
but at the end of the day it never
really seemed to gain the same kind of
popularity he did before and all this
really ran up until about 2006 when the
Marvel cosmology was effectively
consolidated and revamped in its
entirety by a guy named Dan Adnan now
what didn't keep in mind is that the
Marvel cosmology as it existed before
Dan Abnett had taken up the pin and
basically helped to form a lot of it all
it was religious sort of dishevel Marvel
largely focused on earth-based stories
earth-based events because that's where
most of the superheroes dwelled now with
Dan Abbott what are you done is he had
grabbed things like Peter quill who
previously been created revamped his
character in his entirety made him the
new version of star-lord and just kind
of threw him out there grabbing all
these different themes really went into
stories like annihilation were Annihilus
from the negative zone invaded the main
Marvel Universe captured Galactus
different things like that
conquering one planet after another and
it worked exceedingly well
the event of annihilation was going on
for example you had civil war that was
taking place and so on earth you had
superheroes fighting over superhuman
Registration and while that was
happening the universe was being
conquered and so you had times like Nova
Richard Ryder would show up on earth and
say why are you guys fighting over
something so stupid like superhuman
Registration when worlds are falling
left and right in front of a nihilist by
the forces he possesses why does this
matter it was a great contrast to
basically highlight this idea that what
goes on on earth is really irrelevant in
relation to everything that goes on in
the universe and so what this did is it
basically dead-ended into a story called
annihilation conquest and annihilation
conquest effectively saw this kind of
return of Adam warlock now annihilation
conquest itself largely focused on the
idea that Ultron had previously been
defeated and his essence had kind of
been you know escaped out into space or
been shot out into space it also greatly
came across this you know cybernetic
machine based race called the Phalanx
Ultron effectively co-opted the race
made it his own crown himself King and
began the process of trying to conquer
the universe
this led into Moon dragon and it led
into five evelle I think it was
basically forming an alliance waking up
Adam warlock and then bringing him into
the conflict and so it was effectively a
revival of his character now this was
part of a much larger stage for Adam
warlock when it when it came to Dan
Abnett and a lot of it really came to a
head in the events of Thanos imperative
but the idea behind this was to
basically restore Adam warlock back to
being this role of kind of a cosmic
christ-like figure but to also highlight
the idea that he's one of many character
as it exists out there in relation to
the cosmic landscape so it really wasn't
designed to say he was a step above
everybody else so much as he fought
alongside everybody else but what had
happened was that with regards to
defeating Ultron in like annihilation
conquest and several other stories that
took place after that this ultimately
resulted in something called the Thanos
imperative now the Thanos imperative was
actually the aftermath to an event
called the war of Kings and the war of
Kings was basically Vulcan who had taken
over the Shiar Empire as well as
blackballed who had taken over the Kree
Empire going to war with one another and
the idea was that because of the events
of annihilation and annihilation
conquest like a piece of glass the
universe was in a very fragile state and
if someone tapped it the right way he
would basically create this rift and
eventually destroy the universe and so
because of the entire conflict of the
war of kings this led to the detonation
of a massive bomb by Black Bolt and the
Inhumans leading the Kree Empire
created a fissure in the universe and
when it did on the other side of that
fissure was a universe where mistress
death had been killed and nobody else
had been able to die it was basically
called the cancerverse and so in order
to basically keep all these things from
happening Adam warlock had merged
timelines and the timeline he used was
an alternate future where he became the
Magus and what it did is it allowed an
Abnett marvel and all these guys all
these riders to basically grab the
character of the Magus bring that
character back and then launched the
Thanos imperative which again really
kind of saw the return of Thanos
different things like that but this
story culminated in the idea that the
Magus was working for this version of
Captain Marvel in the cancerverse who is
exceedingly evil and wanted to conquer
the main Marvel Universe and so what we
got in the cancerverse were all these
evil versions of superheroes it was all
these evil versions of characters who'd
been caught who'd become corrupted and
so the result was that of course they
were basically defeated famis imperative
came to an end it led to the sacrifice
of Peter quill and of nova santos
eventually ended up escaping there's all
these different things that went on with
regards to this massive climax to a
story that had been building for
somewhere around like you know three or
four years but because of the fact that
the return of the Magus was always this
concept that was haunting Adam warlock
and the idea that the Magus would always
make his return so long as Adam warlock
live in the Thanos imperative ignition
one-shot by Dan Abnett he effectively
wrapped up the character of Adam warlock
in the main Marvel Universe by
effectively having him killed off by
having star-lord kill Adam warlock to
ensure that Magus would never be able to
return now of course this also coincided
with Captain Marvel from the cancerverse
killing Magus as well but the fact
remains here that it was an interesting
concept because following this it kind
of gets a little bit hairy with regards
to Adam warlock
for example stories like infinity
revelation that have this depiction of
Adam warlock and Thanos basically
meeting alternate reality counterparts
so it kind of begs the question does
infinity revelation take place in the
main Marvel Universe and the answer is
not necessarily definitive because
almost all the other infinity stories
infinity abyss different things like
that those take place outside of the
main Marvel Universe infinity revelation
Marvel the end all those things seem to
be outside the main model universe and
in a lot of ways jim Starlin kind of
toyed on them again it's really kind of
weird in terms of how those stories play
out but by and large I would argue the
Thanos imperative was really the last
appearance of Adam warlock
in the main Marvel Universe in terms of
how I would define as appearances in the
main Marvel Universe from there it
really kind of breaks down to jim
Starlin fans who were just like no it's
all in the main Marvel Universe and so
on and so forth and it is kind of
interesting but the fact remains here
again hopefully this helps you guys
understand the nature of Adam you know
what it is he's capable of how he's
evolved over the years but without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to comment
explain and make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
cork you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]